florida is free ron desantis who is the
governor here and his great attorney
general and his great surgeon general
they have decided almost from beat one
two years ago when it was two weeks to
flatten the curve that they were going
to keep the state open they were going
to give as much choice to people as
possible which is obviously
how this should have been managed
and again as i said at the top right now
here in florida if you want to wear a
mask you can but they're not going to
force you to do it they're not going to
force you to be injected with things
it's your choice and you know the good
liberals used to believe in choice
my body my choice not so much anymore
anyway florida has been open and florida
is booming there are all sorts of
metrics on this in terms of the way the
economy is exploding i can assure you uh
having just bought a house that the
house prices are blowing up the market
is crazy uh the amount of influx in
terms of tourists and people that are
coming here and the whole the whole
state it's just it's an exciting place
to be it truly is and it's so exciting
that aoc
you know this woman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
or as gad sad calls her alexandria
occasional cortex
she vacationed
over the christmas break here in miami
so here's a picture of aoc
in florida she's drinking what looks to
be a martini in the middle of the day
that apparently is her boyfriend over
there and uh originally this image
got viral through uh steve cortes who
tweeted it out and made a comment about
the boyfriend's feet because he's
wearing those flip-flops with the socks
okay so be it that's just fine uh
that is sort of irrelevant to the fact
that aoc
who has locked down her people who has
been all about mandates who does not
vote in congress in person she has
someone do it by proxy because of the
pandemic okay this is someone who in
essence has been a lockdown ho okay
that's when i called her on twitter and
now i'm saying it live
she has decided that she would vacation
in florida this is someone who i have no
doubt has said horrible things about ron
desantis has said horrible things about
florida but they are all and this is the
key part guys and we all just need to
know it and then what you do with it is
up to you these politicians and aoc
ain't the only one who do one thing
privately and who lock down their people
publicly and then vacation elsewhere in
the places that they say are the
scariest things
they are
[ __ ] artists
and they're not very good artists
they're just extraordinary bullshitters
so aoc
comes to miami which miami is open and
the weather is good and people are out
and there are crowds and she's having
drinks outside and she's not social
distancing all of that stuff and then
she went to a drag bar on miami beach
and we've got some video
[Applause]
[Music]
good god it could make you puke i mean
these ridiculous people applauding her
applauding her why would you be
applauding this woman you live in
florida or are vacationing to florida
south beach obviously big tourist area
you are all living and or vacationing
here because it's open because it's good
because they haven't destroyed all of
the businesses
be they drag bars or shoe repair shops
and these fools that are applauding her
and she she's there she's hugging people
obviously not social distancing or
masking or any of that stuff they don't
even believe their own [ __ ] and
that's all it is so then after aos aoc
started getting a lot of crap for this
she tweeted this out if republicans are
mad they can't date me they can just say
that instead of projecting their sexual
frustrations onto my boyfriend's feet
you creepy weirdos
it's starting to get old ignoring the
very obvious strange and deranged sexual
frustrations that underpin the
republican fixation on me women and lgbt
plus people in general these people
clearly need therapy won't do it and use
their politics as an outlet instead it's
really weird i mean everything she just
said there i assure you i have no sexual
frustrations related to aoc okay uh
number one number two everything she
just said there is just pure projection
her politics are a projection of her own
desire to run people's lives run
people's world make sure that they have
to abide by her laws while she does not
the people that nobody was really
attacking over her over her boyfriend's
feet nobody cares about his pasty white
feet and his flip-flops and by the way i
don't mind the sock flip-flop thing i've
been known to do it used to live in west
hollywood there were a lot of russians
there that's what they do because it was
cold in russia and then they come to
california it's a little warmer but
you're the sock and the flip-flop i
don't mind it michael's nodding his head
you don't do it but i do do it every now
and again okay
is what it is my frustration
with aoc is that she is an abject fraud
she's a fraud and i'm someone that lives
in the state that you come in to enjoy
yourself while you lock people down i'm
not kidding when i say this i think
florida should pass a law in texas as
well in tennessee and some of the other
red states if you are a lockdown ho like
aoc if you are a politician who locks
down your own people and forces mandates
on people and everything else you cannot
come here i think states are going to
really have to think about things like
that you cannot come here like if you
move to america you have to kind of dig
america right you have to uh know some
things about america you have to know
some stuff about our history you have to
be able to recite the national anthem
etc etc aoc hates america that's obvious
but she hates florida
in the public sense but privately
actually loves florida sorry you
shouldn't be allowed to come here
anymore i'm going to talk to
governor desantis about that oh and then
it gets even better
it gets even better because life
finds a way
uh aoc got coveted yeah so here's a
tweet from aoc's official account
representative
ocasio-cortez has received a positive
test result for covid19 she is
experiencing symptoms and recovering at
home the congresswoman received her
booster shot this fall and encourages
everyone to get their booster and follow
all cdc guidance okay so she's just a
ridiculous clown i'm running out of
adjectives for this woman because she
wasn't following cdc guidelines right
maskless out hugging people huge crowds
blah blah blah vacationed in a place
that allows you to do all that and then
if the vaccines worked and the booster
worked then would she have got covid
we'll do more on that in just a moment
but she did all the stuff right she took
all the vaccines she still got coveted
so and i will just add one other thing i
don't wish anyone uh ill i don't want
her to be sick as much as i don't like
her
but perhaps perhaps maybe
if enough of us point out her hypocrisy
she will wake up to some of this so we
shall
see